[Music]
oh I think I snapped it
stutter oh okay stutter oh okay this is
vintage he hit the Cabbage
ponytail flowing it's like it's like if
Steven Seagal was dunking you know
[Music]
I did that oh did that go away Josh I
it's like this is not the NBA yeah this
is entertainment that's right this is
YouTube this isn't the bubble this
clicks it's clicks baby clickbait I'll
be honest maybe only 30 of the people
watching this video even watched the
current NBA what's the last dunk besides
these that 60 of your audience may have
seen in the last five years I mean we
added 16 30 which is 90 but that's close
oh yeah yeah but the fact that you
called me out of my mouth that's not
good for you
[Music]